make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
this week on our what-if series we are
going to merge two story elements from
the DC and Marvel Universe's and we're
going to introduce one of the biggest
and most constant threats of the Marvel
Universe and discuss what would happen
if Galactus showed up to the DC Universe
so I'm sure all of you know what the
deal is with Galactus he's a cosmic beam
that feeds off the energy of planets
earning him the incredible appropriate
nickname the devourer of worlds while he
has plagued the Marvel Universe for
years and has been a perennial threat to
the mightiest heroes of that universe I
thought it'd be interesting to see what
would happen if Galactus just got bored
of dining on planets from the main
Marvel Universe and decided to venture
over to the DC Universe and try out the
local fare now I think it makes sense
right because sure you can subsist on
like chicken breasts and potatoes for
every meal but every once in a while you
gotta throw in something different to
break the monotony and have some ribs or
pizza or the energy of planets of a
foreign universe and so upon his arrival
in the DC Universe Galactus seeks out a
planet to devour and at a pure
happenstance he arrives at the planet
thanagar the homeworld of Hawkman
Hawkgirl in all the other hawk people
and so Galactus starts setting up his
world engine to extract the planets
energies but since the thanagarians are
formidable warriors they don't take this
lying down and rally their forces to
expel this new threat now well the
thanagarians fight valiantly they're no
match for the immense cosmic power of
Galactus and defeat is imminent
when seemingly out of nowhere the
Justice League shows up and we learn
that they have received a distress call
from Hawkgirl and responded immediately
in the hopes of saving thanagar and so
the Justice League would arrive and
start fighting Galactus and Galactus
will begin to realize that although he
could probably defeat the Justice League
perhaps consuming the planet is not
worth the trouble of enduring a battle
with him and so instead he proposes a
bargain he will spare the planet of
thanagar but in exchange he requires
three of the Justice League members to
serve as his heralds to find him
suitable planets for his consumption and
so hot girl desperate to save her planet
immediately agrees the rest of the
Justice League end up thinking it over
and decide the best course of action is
to agree to the Galactus terms and in
doing so be able to steer him toward
planets that are devoid of sentient life
and so to that end the lead decides that
two of them will volunteer for the
remaining posts Hal Jordan is chosen
because his time as a Green Lantern has
given him a wealth of knowledge about
the universe
and which planets would make good
targets and the flash is also selected
because his SuperSpeed will allow him to
cover a lot of ground exceedingly
quickly seeking out new planets and so
with Hawkgirl Green Lantern and flash
stepping forward as volunteers Galactus
imbues them with a power cosmic a
seemingly unlimited source of cosmic
energy that greatly enhances the power
of those in possession of it and so with
Anna Garr spared and the remaining
members of the Justice League in their
new roles it seems like all as well and
things seem to go well for a little
while right the harrell's were able to
steer Galactus away from planets with
sentient life he's able to remain
reasonably safe but unbeknownst to the
Justice League there are a few forces at
play that threaten to turn this tenuous
alliance sour and threaten the fabric of
the DC Universe itself so it turns out
that the Justice League are not the only
ones aware of Galactus as presence in
the DC universe Darkseid a longtime
antagonist the Justice League has also
found out about Galactus and sees it as
an opportunity to forge an alliance and
achieve his own objective of defeating
the league and conquering earth and then
subjugating the entirety of the DC
Universe and so Darkseid approaches
Galactus with a proposal of his own he
tells Galactus that his heralds have set
him on an unsustainable path that
eventually they will run out of
uninhabited planets for Galactus to feed
on and they will ultimately rebel
against him and so his proposed solution
is to use the anti-life equation to
influence the minds of Galactus as
heralds and make them subservient to him
ultimately realizing the dark sides
right Galactus agrees to this alliance
knowing that his hunger will never truly
be satisfied without feasting on the
energy of life-sustaining worlds and so
Darkseid he uses the anti-life equation
on the heralds and points them towards
earth telling Galactus that because of
all the superheroes there will be more
than enough energy for him to feast on
and so when the heralds show up to
prepare the way for Galactus they are of
course met by the rest of the league who
soon realized that their teammates have
been corrupted and are not in their
right minds and so what's negotiations
with the heralds fail the Justice League
has no choice but to engage their
friends in battle but this goes south
insanely quickly as the power cosmic
coursing to the veins of Hawkgirl flash
and Green Lantern make them immensely
powerful and even the stronger members
of the league like Superman and Wonder
Woman are unable to hold their own
against them and so when all hope is
nearly lost
earth gained some unexpected allies
- unknown warriors appear in the sky and
begin battling Galactus is Herald and
while these new allies are unknown to
the DC heroes we as readers recognize
them immediately as Thor and the Silver
Surfer who have both served as heralds
of Galactus in the past and so as both
of these characters also possess the
power cosmic they are far more capable
of holding their own against the heralds
than the Justice League had been and
once the league talks to them and
figures out who they are and begin
fighting alongside them the battle
becomes fairly evenly matched as we have
the entirety of the Justice League Thor
in the Silver Surfer fighting against
cosmically powered versions of the flash
the Green Lantern and Hawkgirl and so
then we end up cutting to Galactus his
world shipped ha to where he and
Darkseid are watching the battle unfold
below and here we see that Thor and the
surfer were not alone when they made the
trip from the Marvel Universe who were
actually accompanied by the Fantastic
Four as they board Galactus a ship and
request an audience with him now
Darkseid tries to convince Galactus not
to take the meeting but knowing and
respecting Reed Richards as he does
Galactus agrees and so Reed explains
that Galactus his departure from the
Marvel Universe left a fissure in the
barrier between the Marvel and the DC
universes which threatens to throw off
the cosmic balance of both universes and
so Reed employs Galactus to return back
to his native universe and while
Galactus is reluctant to do this he
gives it serious consideration and no
small part to how much of a hassle it
advanced tests to get about this
business of consuming planets since he's
arrived here and so while Galactus
Ponder's Reed's approval Darkseid is
becoming increasingly frustrated now he
assures Galactus that they will soon be
victorious over Earth's defenders and
Galactus will be able to consume the
planet but Galactus has his doubts
knowing how formidable this Silver
Surfer and Thor are as both wield a
power cosmic and so dark side tells
Galactus that he's amassed an army of
parademons that are nearby and ready to
strike at any moment to turn the battle
in their favor but in doing so he makes
a severe miscalculation in revealing to
Galactus what is true motives are
because this is the first time Galactus
has heard of Darkseid bringing an army
he rightfully concludes the Darkseid is
merely using Galactus to achieve his own
mission of destruction and subjugation
and so once dark sides plan has been
exposed he lashes out an anger at the
Fantastic Four for their meddling and
although they do try to fight back
Darkseid proves to be far too much for
them he is not however too much for
Galactus who unleashes a powerful blast
of cosmic energy that sends darks
hurtling across the universe but not
before Darkseid sends a message to his
parademons to attack earth now as a pair
demons do it hack we see that they
number in the thousands and are
accompanied by other members of
Darkseid's army like the female Furies
Kalibak and just for good measure
Darkseid's dog cavalry because every
battle is made better by a bunch of
alien warriors riding giant demon dogs
right now as the forces of apocalypse
advance on earth the Justice League Thor
and silver surfers stand ready to meet
them in combat and this time they're
joined by the flash Green Lantern and
Hawkgirl who Galactus has freed from the
effects of the anti-life equation now
Earth's heroes are able to repel the
first several waves of Darkseid's forces
but additional ways just keep coming and
so Galactus decides to give the heroes
even more aid and he realizes that
Darkseid's forces are agents of
destruction that exists simply for the
sake of causing chaos and that is not
what Galactus is about at all I mean
sure he caused a lot of destruction
himself like he subsists on the energy
of planets but he only does so to sate
his own hunger not through a base desire
to cause death and destruction right so
basically Galactus is attitude as always
like yeah me and Darkseid are really
alike but like it's different when I do
it and so he decides that they need to
be defeated and so he gives part of the
power cosmic to the Fantastic Four as
well in addition to the remaining
members of the Justice League to allow
them to effectively repel the forces of
apocalypse into retreat albeit after a
hard-fought battle which would be the
second large-scale battle of this story
and so with the invading force
effectively defeated Galactus takes back
the power cosmic from all the DC
characters and decides that he's had
enough of this universe and he finds it
too chaotic and largely without any real
order or structure as there seems to be
far fewer cosmic entities in this
universe than there are in the Marvel
Universe to keep things in balance and
so he leaves the DC Universe returns
back to the Marvel Universe where he is
an essential force in maintaining the
cosmic balance and while this seems to
be the end of Galactus his involvement
in the DC Universe we get an epilogue of
sorts it takes place on apocalypse where
Darkseid has returned after being
blasted across the universe by Galactus
now as he meets with his generals he
expresses his disappointment over their
failure on earth but admits that they
have little hope of winning due to the
immense cosmic power working against
them however he does say that it'll no
longer be a problem because wal aboard
tattoo he was able to acquire a valuable
new weapon
stealing it without Galactus realizing
it and he stays if this weapon is one
that will finally turn the tide in
apocalypses favor once and for all and
in the final panel we see dark side
holding none other than the ultimate
nullifier which sets us up with all
kinds of possibilities for an epic
storyline later on down the road but let
me know what you guys think I think it's
kind of cool I think it's really really
really cool right like the Justice
League becoming heroes of Galactus right
but let me know you guys think down in
the comment section if you guys are new
here to come as explained make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]